we're spending yet another lesson
focusing on a particular aspect of what
we know about quadratic equations
particularly we're gonna think about
graphing means we already know in some
ways how to graph them we've encountered
these before but we're going to kind of
do it in a more systematic way and we're
also going to lead into some other
topics we're learning this morning
now before I thought we'd jump in I
wanted to spend a very brief moment to
sort of say why are we why do we keep
looking at these things like we've been
looking at them for years at this point
and you're like this is the I've looked
at this multiple times and we're only a
week four come on why can't we move on
to something else and in fact just like
kind of fractions that I would you break
fractions so we looked at the other way
week we will keep looking at these
things now I thought I would take a
different approach rather than say hey
these are all of the reasons why these
are all the the future topics that are
going to deal with quadratics and
continued into them I thought I would do
something different and kind of
illustrate why not just the course does
like it looks at quadratics over and
over again but one of the people who
designed the course why did they
actually put it into the curriculum
because this is a question I myself
didn't know the answer to for a long
time so here's the way I think this
should make sense the best right of all
of the functions that we deal with we
spend a lot of time on polynomials like
straight lines right we learn about
these like a long time ago way before
quadratics and was just this simple
object we've also very briefly looked at
when you have really high powers like if
you've got a cubic or a quartic when the
power at the front is not X x squared
but X cubed or a power of 4 we're going
to spend more time looking at those as
well but then we have right in the
middle of here there's this little
interesting spot these quadratics now
why would this be the spot that we spend
lots of time and attention on why do we
spend more time graphing these and
analyzing them than any other kind of
these other what sorts of functions okay
okay now we we often spend a lot of time
on how many kinds of answers are there
to do these kinds of things and I think
that's actually a really wonderful spot
to jump off on because if I could show
this to you again it's about graphics no
one trades to you visually if you think
in that straight lines
there are actually such simple objects
that they are in a sense boring like you
you know every single thing about one of
these kinds of objects from fairly early
on there's only really a handful of
things to know how steep is it like
which direction is it facing and then
potentially you know where does it hit
your two axes and that's kind of it full
stop right I suppose if you want to be
really interesting you could put two of
them on a graph and you can solve them
simultaneously but it ends up being the
same kind of problem like there's
nothing extra interesting about these
and because straight lines are so simple
there are very few actual at natural
phenomena that are modeled really well
by straight lines things in real life
often don't like to go in straight lines
but for things that go in curvy lines
good morning what's the time this thank
you when you have a look at the other
end right well you get past quadratics
when you think about all these other
Wiggly weird graphs which have higher
powers they start to become too complex
to deal with in like our time frame you
start to have to deal with like you need
computers to actually analyze these
things and work out where the solutions
are tools that we don't really either
have access to or don't want to devote
the time to like we have so many other
interesting things within the course to
spend time on now to show you what I
mean by how difficult this is right why
they're the awkward and done gross to
deal with right think back to when you
are dealing with quadratic equations
when you can't factorize something when
you don't want to complete the square we
have a nice neat way of just arriving at
the probability to soldiers you're going
to check what is that method it's not
factorizing it's not complete the square
its wrestle yeah it's yet the quadratic
the quadratic formula thank you right
when we're dealing with quadratic
equations we use the formula to then
solve it and of course we know the
formula are pretty well by now right now
fun fact this is the quadratic formula
right there are formulas for the other
kinds of equations too for example there
is a cubic formula so if I gave you if I
gave you a cubic equation like this
whoops that's a 3 so this is just like
one of the quadratic equations that
we've dealt with a lot but it's just
like a little bit more complicated just
a little bit like there's only one
extra turn okay watch what happens to
the formula and its complexity when we
just add one term this is the quadratic
formula this monstrosity is the cubic
formula now you can see why we don't
make you learn this thing right
what would be the point like it is just
insanely complicated and it's not just
insanely complicated even if you could
solve this thing which you actually can
write I just the look on your face it if
you can't solve this see by the time you
get the end of it you're like really
what was the point what extra did we
learn let me give you an example I said
you know if I gave you a cubic formula
so here's a cubic formula and I've
actually put some numbers in okay so
it's like one lot of X cubed no X
Squared's that many X's that's a
constant term on the end okay now if you
took that gross-looking cubic formula
that I just showed you and you take
these numbers and put them in okay this
is the graph that we you can put this
into decimal so you can see what happens
right so you should be able to get some
answers out of this but then something
really weird and bizarre happens right
just have a look at what has just
occurred right the cubic formula let me
just go back the cubic formula has all
of these groups I've gone too many has
all these cube roots and then it's got
square roots underneath the cube roots
right so it's this awful object okay now
when you substitute everything in and
simplify it all out you get this on your
first line now can anyone tell me
anything weird about this particular
line it's not a typo yeah yeah there are
negative numbers two of them or the same
one twice underneath the square root and
apparently well in our world that what
we've been working with you're not
supposed to do that right you're
supposed to say at that line no real
solutions that's what you're supposed to
say okay but just so happens they're a
bunch of Italian mathematicians back in
the 1500 to 1600 they were willing to
ask the question well what if what if
you couldn't do that they went ahead and
they gave that thing a name right and
I'm not going to get into that moment
they had to develop that a horn you feel
a whole new branch of mathematics to
deal with these objects to give it a
name and then to like work out what
answers you get out of it
it gets even more complicated like I
don't know if you know what double the
cube root of 5 root 5 times cause of a
third of 10
inverse of that number is right you're
like this is so awful this is terrible
there's by the way a lot of lines have
working between here and here to try and
work out how do i how do you work out
the cube root of a number that doesn't
even exist what is up with that right
and then after all of that huge amount
of work surprise surprise after feeling
so anxious you get an answer like this
and that's exactly the way you can
actually put all of that into your
calculator and it's not even
approximation there it is right over
there you see on my graph like do you
see where 4 is can you just make it I
know that the scale is a bit small but
there is it's the third solution along
right you're like what I had to invent a
whole new branch of mathematics and do
all of this incredibly fine detail work
I actually got this question wrong like
seven or eight times when I was solving
this for myself before I arrived at the
proper solution and that you do all of
that for this ok do you see now why we
love quadratics right they are
sufficiently complicated that there's
some interesting behavior to investigate
but they're sufficiently simple that we
don't have to mess with all of this and
it's a bit of a disaster ok